how old ov ACTU uh well there's my
thumbnail damn mm well then that's a
good introduction if I've ever seen one
welcome guys back to potato mode the
show where we take the greatest looking
games we know and then we just turn them
into mush
I'm Joey I'm joined by Eric what's up
guys and we are dived into some Mortal
Kombat X 10 and X Excel Excel tactically
so if you haven't seen a show before
we're gonna show off just how great the
game looks first and then slowly but
surely make a way down the ladder and
try to turn the graphics into something
unrecognizable hopefully it's still one
of those things where the fatalities and
the brutalities are so gruesome that
like you'll keep coming back yeah it's
just fun it's kind of fun to watch this
where it'll go but then it's also kind
of just kind of disgusting gruesome
definitely not safe for work it's train
wreck basically you can't stop watching
giblets so a lot of giblets yeah have
you ever watched like some of the behind
the scenes of like how they get some of
these noises they just like have like
this random stuff they have like goop
that does just like a throw on the
ground or like alright so what are we
doing so we're going to the main menu
okay and we're just gonna try to bring
everything down as much as much as we
can that the game will give us a CC
video everybody it looks okay yeah like
the backgrounds I think maybe is it
because the textures are so so much
further away I don't know oh no I still
see it I still see it I can't unsee it
alright I don't think this is this seems
a little bit half-baked not a fully
baked potato okay kind of like a half
one okay so I think
so we're gonna go back to the main menu
we're gonna go even further so I'm gonna
are you gonna get it real quick use your
magic magic there we go and go already
we got here Mortal Kombat X for the
Nvidia profile inspector something that
sure a lot of fans of the show have
become very familiar with this is this
is your like top hat it was later one
your magic wow this is well this is
where the sausage is all made some
people would say oh all right this is
this is more of a potato mode episode if
I've ever seen one there's so much worse
earlier let's see it's brutal
I guess this is how you censor a Mortal
Kombat game right just right it's like
basically it's like all right kids hold
on let's turn on the potato fire now you
can play Mortal Kombat it's okay yeah
exactly
[Music]
now look way cooler than readin there's
my fire oh yeah no this is Oh this oh
that's a pretty good one that's that's
pretty look at his tongue lady's tongue
wiggle whose brain no that's something
else that's like it's like the pink
sludge that you pointed McDonald's
chicken nuggets yeah yeah yeah quit
classic lost an arm I can't even tell
the other heads it's actually that's
actually real creepy oh I don't like how
those other things look a couple of them
that are looking really shiny right so
got it have a drink
was this one yeah oh no oh okay it's
like a sausage oh he's making sausage
that's actually not that bad it's all
right yeah it's just one long piece of
sausage or a tapeworm
yeah we helped him yeah it's almost as
if we helped him be like pumped his
stomach you know we've had to get it as
goro after a long night out of the dream
at the bars not a good look oh yeah oh
yeah he really is like a bug oh that was
pretty
I really like though that was pretty
good that was pretty good Oh what are
those does even would she do she's
through bugs that you can't really see
because like they're barely there it's
almost like it's snow and we're on a
snow level but we're not cuz those are
actually insects oh yeah what's oh yeah
oh yeah the eye comes out
yeah well I am still twitching mind
games oh yeah oh this one this one's
really bad too with the graphics dad
this is a little less safer work yeah
but if you saw the real deal
this one's that one's pretty bad yeah
yeah oh God
oh yeah bubble gum I feel like that
should have been a lot worse too
I mean that was still pretty bad it's
pretty brutal where is it it was actual
Gore though there's a little bit car
yeah it looks like confetti though hmm
what are those they look like Mentos no
big Mentos you what they are you'll just
like popper things that you get from the
arcades and you like turn them inside
out leave them on the table and then
they just pop up that's basically what
it was inside of him this whole time
oh man got the Nicolas Cage that dual
Gold's oh wait how do you shoot them
through the side is like a smiley face
almost it's a nice jacket I have to say
it's a design part of what you're buying
here got it oh yeah it's like a really
bad old looking toy oh this is not
nearly as bad as we were it's like jello
it's jello normally you would see all of
the other body parts and like all this
other stuff and all we have is his hand
his face and whatever that is
nice nice jell-o mold the finale right
here I mean the tentacles pretty good
you got the suction cups on it yep
darkness well I think that about does it
for this episode potato mode safe for
work edition the safe for work edition
you can you can show this episode to
your friends and family bring it to your
kids birthday parties all that good
stuff skip the first life minute though
where we actually showed the real game
anyway thanks so much for watching thank
you Eric for bringing us through all
those a beautiful beautiful fatalities
fun to come back and make another
compilation except in a way safer manner
yeah if you guys have a game you want to
suggest to us make sure to leave it in
the comments below you can hit us up on
Twitter and all that thanks so much for
watching and we will see you all next
Friday little guess yeah give some px'
gasps i'm a flatulent man okay